c'est marshall bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
cela fait des années que des tensions
sont très vives entre addis abeba et le
tigre et ses provinces du nord du pays
pourquoi ce conflit politique s'est-il
aujourd'hui transformé en escalade
militaire
ecoutez-la bon l'arrivée au pouvoir de
habib ahmed l'actuel premier ministre
éthiopien et d'armements dus à une
défaite politique du front populaire de
libération du tigre haye et disons il
était clair que cette première victoire
allait assez première victoire allait
succéder une série d'escarmouches dans
la mesure où le front populaire de
libération du tig my avait fourni
pendant plus de 20 ans l'essentiel des
cadres de du dip state enfin de l'état
profond 1 2 de l'appareil sécuritaire et
et militaires éthiopiens et que à partir
de ce moment là une lecture complotistes
pouvait voir dans toute difficulté du
président habib une tentative de
manipulation de cette organisation
politique dont qui règne aujourd'hui et
qui contrôle le tigre haye d'un autre
côté le front populaire du tigre haye et
retournez donc dans sa région d'origine
puisqu'il da ilha du il était devenue
minoritaire à addis abeba et dans les
mois qui ont suivi on a constaté
plusieurs choses d'une part des citoyens
du tigre à et ont été attaqués dans
différents endroits et pas simplement
dans des zones territoriales contestées
mais également dans les universités a
pas eu
sans vouloir parler de chasse à l'homme
il ya eu quand même des incidents tout à
fait regrettable et évidemment aux
tigres heile
fpl t a essayé de retrouver une
légitimité qu'il avait largement perdu
du fait de son de sa prise de pouvoir à
addis abeba nous fait de profiter de
profiter en fait les revenus de l'état
central donc les élections qui ont eu
lieu au mois de septembre ont d'une
certaine façon permis dans des
conditions qui sont disons qu'on peut
discuter mais qui ne sont pas mauvaises
au fplp de retrouver une légitimité
populaire dans sa région d'origine et en
même temps de souligner un point qui est
très douloureux pour l'actuel président
au premier ministre éthiopien c'est à
dire le fait que les élections en
ethiopie ont été retardés de façon
officielle à cause de l'épidémie du
comité 19 mai beaucoup prétendent et
notamment parmi des observateurs que
c'est aussi une stratégie pour ce délai
correspond à une stratégie pour asseoir
la construction d'un nouveau parti
politique qui remplacerait la coalition
qui avait gouverné l'ethiopie depuis
et donc on a effectivement une c'est une
guerre très politique
pour l'heure en même temps il faut pas
se cacher que les les les tensions que
ça peut créer dans la société
éthiopienne peuvent déboucher sur des
choses qui seront assez terrible de tout
l'inquiétude de l'union africaine et des
pays amis et doux aussi le fait qu'il le
faut retourner à la table de négociation
public possible
pourtant depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
ah mais ahmed a tenté de fédérer le pays
voulait créer une sorte d'unité on sait
que d'ailleurs cela lui a valu le prix
de nobel de la paix en 2019 pourquoi
finalement il n'a pas réussi dans sa
mission jusqu'à aujourd'hui
écoutez les je crois qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer les difficultés auxquelles
il a été confronté
là il est arrivé au pouvoir largement
parce que le fplp la coalition que cette
organisation dirigée avait échoué pas
échoué pour quelques mois avait échoué
pendant des années à trouver le
dérèglement acceptable par de larges
fractions de la population éthiopienne
donc évidemment changer de dirigeant
c'est bien mais ça veut pas dire que les
conflits sont réglés ça effectivement
permis un certain nombre d'évolutions
extrêmement positives qui ont valu à
monsieur habib ahmed le le prix nobel de
la paix largement d'ailleurs à cause de
la de la signature d'une normalisation
avec l'erythrée donc ça concerne peu la
situation intérieure éthiopienne mais il
ya eu le retour de l'organisation d'ici
d'entamer enfin il ya eu des choses qui
ont été extrêmement positives mais d'une
certaine façon le coeur des discussions
et le coeur des oppositions d'un n'a pas
été atteint et abbey s'est retrouvé très
rapidement face à une situation à des
situations délicates et je crois que les
observateurs notent que l'autoritarisme
dont faisait preuve le fplp lorsqu'il
était au pouvoir a été largement
reproduits par son successeur
juste après l'obtention du prix nobel de
la paix il ya la question serait très
très rapidement vous parliez justement
de l'union africaine qui s'inquiète un
petit peu de ce conflit qui se
généralise est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'organisation voilà peu pesé
dans ce conflit est justement mettre un
terme à ces hostilités selon vous
écouter il ya il ya très certainement
des des amis de l'ethiopie pour les
appeler ainsi à commencer par les états
unis le royaume uni l'union européenne
la chine qui sont des partenaires
extrêmement important de l'ethiopie qui
joue un rôle
dans les corridors simplement à l'heure
actuelle il est vrai que le il serait il
peut sembler préférable de donner la
primeur en tous les cas au niveau
médiatique à l'union africaine
quand bien même les discussions sont
ailleurs merci beaucoup
roland marchal d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur au cnrs et spécialiste des
guerres civiles en afrique